well a big seller this holiday season is
michael bolton's christmas album
this is the time happy birthday jesus
hope you like crap
this cable cafe stokes a culture war
that's more
manufactured than ronaldo's top teeth i
mean here's a perfect
example take america's longest running
war the war on christmas yup
it's the same every year big brands say
happy holidays not because they want to
take down more christians than a pissed
off
pilot not that pilot that's better as
what those romans said
but because they want to make money off
of everyone the only profit they want to
see risen is their own
but thanos karen laura ingram who looks
like spray tan tom petty
tells us target is trying to erase
christianity and
suddenly the think peace patrol is
trading barbs with thumb head hannity
and we're all supposed to believe that
anyone gives a flying [ __ ] about this
flying [ __ ] the fact is we all love
christmas
muslims jews hindus normal people
we don't care if you wish us a merry
christmas a happy holidays or a terrific
toyota
year-end event this is kind of [ __ ]
weather
i'm going to tell you what causes it
it's you
you
you [ __ ] christians
seriously seriously pushing
the limits of what the planet can take
in terms of christmas
you wanna
you wanna jack off the calendar that's
what you're [ __ ] doing
your [ __ ] holiday is in december
okay and when you [ __ ] with the goddamn
calendar the weather doesn't know what
to do
i've said this time and again there's
nothing we
jews can do about the [ __ ]
incessant [ __ ] nonsense that i've
watched
all day as i watch what i wanted to
watch was football
but instead i got santa jacking off in
my
face i don't need it
i don't [ __ ] need it
all right you've completely
[ __ ] thanksgiving you just took that
holiday
and said hey [ __ ] you
you don't even matter anymore nothing
happened in plymouth rock
the [ __ ] dude [ __ ] kris kringle
showed up that [ __ ] nazi
and fed everybody there were no indians
around
god damn it it really is unbelievable
it's [ __ ] december 1st
to december 25th but that's not enough
it's not enough for you
you don't there's a war on christmas no
there's not
there's a war on hanukkah
and and you didn't even have to declare
war
we won we're a little shit-ass holiday
it's a piece of [ __ ] holiday i ought to
know cause i'm a jew
it is [ __ ] stupid
no comparison to christmas [ __ ] none
stupid [ __ ] let's light some candles
you've got electricity
[ __ ] you
american you're a racist we brought up
from the beginning to think in
generalizations
we never look at the individual we
rarely look an individual i'm a racist
i know i'm a racist you know how i know
the other day i caught myself
being racist against myself it's someone
should get known i got
mixed up forgot whose team i was on and
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
one time i was reading the paper man
this story came on about the uh
this guy was suing a department store
because they wouldn't let him play santa
claus you know cause he's black
and i was actually like relieved when
the department store beat him that's bad
but i wasn't ready for that i wasn't
ready for the idea of a black santa
claus man that [ __ ] would suck
so we wouldn't get our presents to the
28th 29th
[Applause]
sorry kids
[Applause]
[Music]
santa got caught up with some [ __ ] in
vegas
i had to sell some toys to get bats yeah
where them cookies at
well how was christmas okay christmas
was um
it's a lot of stress yeah it's really
hard
because the pressure is enormous i have
two kids right and it has to be great
right and it has to be even like one kid
can't have a better christmas than the
other one
so you keep upping the ante the pressure
is so much i start getting a stomach
ache
like in november i start getting really
anxious about christmas
and this year it got to be like december
5th i had gotten nothing for either of
them
like not one present for either kid and
the thought occurred to me for the first
time
what if i got nothing what if i just
don't get anything
what if this one christmas they get
nothing right
not very little but zero
just stuff up the chimney and don't buy
nothing right and just they come down
and there's just
nothing and they're like what i'm like
yeah just there's nothing here girls
and they're like did santa come well if
he did he didn't leave anything not for
you not for you
did you buy and say no i did were we bad
no you just didn't get anything
you just didn't get anything for
christmas and just watch them go
just watch them like taking it i
actually think
that it would make them better people i
actually do think
that one christmas with nothing would
make them more generous
more more cautious and smarter people
yeah so it actually would be good
parenting to have one yeah that would be
good
nothing yeah hey what's going on it's
bill burr and it's time for the monday
morning podcast for monday november
6th 2016. holy [ __ ] dude i gotta start
my [ __ ] christmas shopping
you know what you actually should at
this point wouldn't that be great would
it be great to just think of every
[ __ ] goddamn person out there that
you gotta buy for no not your kids
all right you love your kids not your
dog you love your dog
right what else is this your kids and
your dog that's what it is right you
love your wife too but you know
you know this right wouldn't it be great
if there you could just [ __ ] go
just get it all [ __ ] done just call
in sick one day you know exactly where
you want to go
[ __ ] give me one of those give me
[ __ ] like a dunkin donuts
give me uh two [ __ ] jellies a [ __ ]
powdered sugar [ __ ]
too glazed in a curler all right except
it's gifts
you know then you just have the lady
down there wrap them for you
the whole [ __ ] i mean nice gifts
though nice
thoughtful [ __ ] for like 10 15 [ __ ]
people but you just knock it out in four
hours
right then you take these fake hay fever
pills and you walk into words like oh
god i just woke up
i'll be all right i'll be in my cubicle
whatever you did the whole [ __ ] thing
is done
right then you can just sit there and
chill
two things you should [ __ ] do i would
this is why i'm actually talking out
loud to myself
and i'm not mad if you're listening all
right two things you got to do you got
to do [ __ ] cardio right through the
new year because you know you're going
to eat and drink like a [ __ ] pig
you know it's happening all right you
know it's the end of the year
you know what i mean you get those few
days off and you just start thinking
what if we just always had days off
and everybody just [ __ ] cooked and
you [ __ ] drank and nobody gave a [ __ ]
and there wasn't anything to do
the next day you know that wonderful
feeling of actually
living life while enjoying it
as opposed to looking at dread at your
[ __ ] watches
this is the next [ __ ] mondays coming
you know so if you can just somehow
knock it out you know what i mean
knock it out before the animals show up
you know
i mean it's just [ __ ] it all starts
on black friday and then it just becomes
[ __ ] just
bad fathers and i don't know what into
december and all of that [ __ ] so
you knock that out you do your half hour
of cardio every [ __ ] day go for a
walk whatever [ __ ] you do eat a salad or
some [ __ ]
just do something you know so you know
as i'm sitting here drinking a [ __ ]
miller high life doing this [ __ ]
podcast
um i should do that i should make a
[ __ ] list in my head right now all
the nieces and nephews what do they want
how old are they
bang bang boom i don't like that
internet shopping though you know
you just go on amazon you just go around
just clicking [ __ ]
some reason it's not as [ __ ] cool um
i actually found it
accidentally found this really cool toy
store
of course i was going out to a bar
and it was closed and everything but it
actually had like
wooden toys like cars and [ __ ] like that
like
uh you know the way they used to make
them
they didn't make them that way when i
was a kid i remember my daddy say that
christian is cheap [ __ ]
well that was a kid crisis that was made
out of metal and warden
the tires were real rubber right
and our [ __ ] was all [ __ ] plastic and
god knows what else you put it in your
mouth the next thing you know
you were bad at math and you couldn't
read out loud so you had to start
telling jokes
that's what happened everything i was
born during a [ __ ] time
when any [ __ ] toy when you were a kid
if you were the little kid going through
the oral stage you know they just stick
that whole [ __ ] hand in their mouth
all your little brothers and [ __ ] every
[ __ ] toy you had they put in their
mouth
that was it you know they went from an a
student down to a b
student and then they had all the
colorful cereals with all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] in it
they had fluff peanut butter and fluff
sandwiches we man it was just [ __ ] it
was a sugar coma
um oh and i gotta tell you it was great
oh jesus christ you need to fluff
another sandwich then you put on the
banana splits or the monkeys
you know with the whole influence of the
acid generation
it's a good time um
[Music]
you